[Musique]
ce samedi 16 juin était la journée
nationale des sapeurs pompiers
à cette occasion un lieu une cérémonie
de remise de distinctions et
l'inauguration de nouveaux centres
d'incendié et de secours de saint pierre
en présence de série melchior président
du département de michel fontaine maire
de saint-pierre de frédéric are su
préfet
il ya des centres qui sont délabrés qui
ont été construits là bien longtemps il
ya d'autres centres que nous louons
auprès de personnes extérieures aux
disques et bien aujourd'hui le this
constitue son propre patrimoine grâce
bien sûr subventions du département et
aux participations de la commune ça va
enclencher un vaste plan pluriannuel
d'investissement lors ce sombre si
caserne qu'ils vont être lancées quatre
ou cinq qui sont en cours de livraison 6
qui vont être lancés et donc cela
représente plus de 20 millions d'euros
d'investissement
ce magnifique équipement permettra aux
hommes et aux femmes sapeurs-pompiers
d'exercer leurs missions dans de
meilleures conditions
[Musique]